President, I am crying from the European Council,
Ursula von der
Leyen's request shows President and since
many of you have
obviously raised the issue of the bric site,
I would like to say a few words on this
subject in response to your interventions.
many of you have said that this is the
very first time that your parliament has
debated the break site, knowing that it
will really take place on 31 January from
now on and I say this with
great respect, also with great
understanding,
I  what are you doing yesterday's speech aceh
garcía pérez by dacian cialos de ska
keller also from several of you a
lot of understanding with regard to
all this many of you
here outside this hemicycle who would have
liked  that the united kingdom remains in
the union but we also express
respect for the British choice from
the beginning is our responsibility
ladies and gentlemen members of Parliament
our mission that which has been entrusted to me
c  is precisely to respect the
will expressed by a majority of
British citizens is therefore
to organize the orderly withdrawal in
the interest of the citizens in the interest of
the
economy both sides and in the interest of
the future also at  through a treaty that
is now here that you know
well since we kind of
built that together i in turn want to
thank the president steering group and
all the parliamentarians who
participated in particular different stadt
now we are about to
look more  towards the future and
i remember what our president
ursula von der leyen said right here
on november 27
whatever our future the ties
and friendship between our peoples will remain
indestructible
that's the line have fun
members for the times to come and
that is what will lead us to
work in a respectful and
ambitious manner
towards a very strong and strategic relationship
with  the united kingdom
it will base this relationship on an
economic pillar which we will
work on it in particular with
commissioner phil hogan and all the
other commissioners concerned under
the authority of the president is a
strategic partner
we will work on it as a priority
with the high representative joseph bourrel
and other commissioners the united kingdom
will remain, as you said,
a friendly country an allied country a partner country and
we must translate this alliance
this friendship this partnership into
new treaties I would like to remind you
that the framework of this
very ambitious future relationship  it is written
very precisely in the last 36 pages
of this document that you have in front of you
and I want to apply this document
this political declaration it is
common
every word counts every word has been approved
by us and by boris johnson and yet
another  time every word counts
what can limit this
ambition ladies and gentlemen started
from  two things 1 time the time
we need to translate this
ambition into treaties or
texts 2 obviously the differences that
may arise between our interests and
our objectives and in particular the
responses that the United Kingdom will provide
in the coming weeks  to a
question the united kingdom left the union
we respect this choice he does
not leave europe obviously does he want to
move away in what proportion from
our regulatory model and
this is the question that is asked this is the
answer  which will be provided by the
United Kingdom which will determine the level of our
ambition from today we have
three projects to carry out together one the
conclusion of the process of ratification
of the withdrawal agreement
2 the implementation of the agreement  even
in all its dimensions this point
is not negligible both for the
citizens whose rights written in this
text must be respected and also
I take the liberty of reminding the
President  dente I also say so that
she looks and ascione kelly and to others
in ireland and in northern ireland for
peace stability and then the third
project is that of the future of the
new  negotiation in a limited time
we have heard the first
British say that he will not want to
ask for an extension of the
transition
this extension is possible it
will remain possible until June 30
by mutual agreement which means that
each of the two partners  the union and
the united kingdom can say yes or to
say no until June 30
but this time is limited so will
not be possible
if I continue to be very frank with
you in this limited time to do everything
but we will do our best  possible
we can't do it all that will give 'em
all is therefore naturally if we
want to deliver
the new relationship in all its
dimensions at the end of the road we will have to take more
time and continue beyond the end of
the transition end  2020  beyond
continue to work with the
British and to negotiate
here I want to make a last
commitment under the authority of the
president chantal dionne and with the
confidence of the president of the
european council and yours we will continue
to work with the same method
transparency
your frankness the dialogue with all
the commissioners concerned and with the
services of the commission i should
say a last word to mr michael
yvr just now who spoke
very vehemently and
telling us we are proud  to be
British
obviously we respect we
understand this pride but mr the
deputy yves hours we are all here
proud to be patriots all and we
do not have a lesson in patriotism to
receive from you
the only thing that I want to say is  is
that to our patriotism to our pride
in being a patriot we add here an
additional dimension
we believe that our patriotism and
today and will be  tomorrow in the world
she who comes more solid because
we add to it the union of europeans and
the joint action of europeans
thank you sir daniel delas and
christiane madam president
sheikh member of the european parliament
thank you for the different messages that
have been sent for  the opinions that
have been expressed the first point the
climate was indeed last week
the number one issue for this European summit
thank you for the encouragement that has
been expressed but I fully appreciate all the
work that still remains to be done and
particularly the need very
quickly to agree only
2030 objective to prepare us
for the next cups in particular in
glazoué we will do it with the
commission taking into account
the assessments necessary to
continue progress on this subject
second element
yes it is an act  important which was
asked last week by the
European Council because the decision it is
unanimous is  ant of the climate neutrality objective
by 2050
and it is only for the implementation
that a European country acts have generated
that more time was necessary we
will come back to it
specifically on this subject at least in
June within the  European Council
third element we have opened
the financing site because
indeed to be credible and
realistic this question of financing
is essential we will continue it
in the coming months, in particular but
not only with regard to the debate on the
next budget their full and finally
points  complementary
several have mentioned it I also believe
that this strong position taken by the
European authorities youpine green deal
climate neutrality in 2050
gives the European authorities
institutions with a
clear mandate at the international level,
particularly within the framework of the zorro summits of
the year  next with China
because to advance this agenda for
international and also by success j
I deeply believe that this decision,
which is very essential, creates the
conditions to put Europe in a
position tomorrow to have champions
for whom 2020 is a good thing
for prosperity for stability
for development and
for innovation as well and  finally watch
watch regardless of the
impatience that i respect and that i
hear the path traveled in a
few months just a few months ago in from the
summit of sibiu it was at the beginning of
the year 2010 9 only nine
european countries on the  twenty-seven share
this 2005 climate neutrality objective
in a few months later unanimity
to meet this message is in very good
shape which is addressed second point the
question of the european budget i share
point and expressed in particular by
mr ben and by other
european parliamentarians  it's an
extremely difficult project
that's why long before
it would be last week I took a
lot of  I have time, Mr. Deputy,
to meet one-on-one with the
various European leaders to understand
the priorities to understand the spaces for
negotiation and the spaces for compromise
but I am also counting on political coherence the
political alliance
the incense of political leaders
because  that I hear here a line of
force of the gaves and ambitions which
are legitimate
in terms of capacity for action
through the European budget
but I see at the site around the table
of the European Council I am with
leaders next to me  european heads
of state and prime ministers who
each face national parliaments tone
for the two political majorities
with parties represented in this
european parliament i also count alain dufour
an ability to carry the debate with
political coherence the canton addresses
now national at European level
either the same messages are
carried by the political formations
for which you are leaving  is presented
to the voters
finally third element i do not want to
escape the question
malta is the rule of law i am going to be
very clear about this
extremely important subject
the rule of law is a foundation is a
founding value of the european project
and  the assassination of a journalist is
obviously first of all a drama for
families is a drama for loved ones
a human drama
but this beyond this human and
personal drama for families is a
serious and serious attack on
freedom  of the press which is one of the
fundamentals of this project the meal which
unites us and brings us together
investigations are underway they must
be based on the principles of the rule
of law in the face of the separation of
powers
it is up to the
European institutions everyone  in its role without
responsibility as the
European parliament in marathons of reflection
event on the subject to assume their
responsibilities I will not escape
my responsabil  ities
each time it will be a question of defending
the rule of law without this spirit also
that I announced my disposition
met the family of seven
murdered journalists
finally a name again on the break site and
I would like to repeat turns here again  that
each time and it started with the
referendum three years ago now
i have expressed my respect for the
positions expressed through the
referendum by the british people
i regret this decision but i
respect this decision expressed by the
british people
the european council  to last week
and michel barnier has just said it again
with great precision has set
himself up for the next steps
we know which direction we
want we know where we want to
go we know that transparency
is unity will be the  keys
to ensuring that these negotiations are
fair etc. are respectful
we will protect defend European interests
level play  g field
the interest also of preserving the integrity
of the internal market there must be a
lot of calm with a lot
of calm it will always be in my mind
yesterday's gathering to
those I heard in this assembly
once again we  practiced
boring insult and slur
rather than argument tell them
I won't be
intimidated by this spirit of controversy
serve it with calm and determination we
will defend a strong close relationship
for the future with the  great britain
finally i conclude these few words
by reiterating the conviction ambitions
confidence and common sense ambitions
confidence and common sense it is in my opinion
the lines of conduct which must
dominate the action of the institutions without
ever forgetting that each institution there
and for  carry the hopes and dreams of
European citizens and ensure that
this project that mobilizes us is a
project that brings light to the future
thank you michel
[App  laudations]